welcome back even a tribute to Dr King
couldn't stop Joe from doing his thing
Drew Biden's still a divisive ass
jabbering about guns race and gas
not his own by the way
during his MLK Day speech the president
gave a speech so off the rails they had
to call Pete butterjudge
because he's the transportation
secretary a little play on words there
first there was this nonsense about the
GOP and spending
you're going to talk about big spending
Democrats again guess what God I reduced
the deficit last year
350 billion dollars
and this year
Federal deficit is down one trillion
plus dollars
hear me that's a fact but so what these
guys are there
you know they're fiscally demented I
think they don't they don't quite get it
fiscally demented well if anybody's
familiar with dementia
one day I just wanted him to whisper
this will be our little
[Laughter]
but let's not forget the fact that Joe
just signed an absurd 1.7 trillion
dollar spending Bill last month it was
the first spending Bill signed with a
crayon later he accused car insurance
companies to charging higher premiums
based on race
if you're live in one of those
neighborhoods and you have the same
exact car I have in the other
neighborhood you pay more for your
insurance in that size no basis for it
none at all other than you're black and
I'm white
stop bragging
sorry Joe the only time insurance
companies care if someone's white is to
avoid casting them in their commercials
of course Joe should pay the higher
premium his car is filled with
classified documents boom yeah huh a
little political humor there very little
boom yeah ah here's your red meat
but what better day to stoke racial
division than on MLK day one man had a
dream and the other one's barely awake
what a good time to talk about getting
assault weapons banned huh
I am going to get assault weapons banned
what the hell you need a assault no I'm
serious and ban the number of bullets
and go in a magazine there's no no need
for any of that I love my right-wing
friends to talk about the tree of
Liberty as water of the blood of
patriots
come here if you need to work about
taking on the federal government you
need some f-15s you don't need an RAR
15. I'm serious he's serious he's only
told that story 170 times so wait you
need an F-15 to take on the government
but an unarmed face painted Q Anon
Shaman almost toppled democracy
get your story straight Gramps
now I'm sure you already saw this and
unlike Joe it will never age
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
[Music]
happy birthday to you
I told you oh my God you know it's a
shame because he spent all night
memorizing happy birthday
so
so Joe anything else to add
no no no no no look look these tough
guys with their guns we didn't have
those growing up on the main streets of
Wilmington Delaware with guys like Corn
Pop we had to use our bare hands that's
right in fact I ran into some Bad Dudes
the other day
I remember how that went
I remember
you looking at old man stay out of my
garage
you better get your ass off while I
still let you there's nothing in there
except my Corvette and uh
some boxes
crazy can I get out of here man why
don't you get your ass up out of here
before I kick your old wrinkly white ass
and you and you I pointed all of you you
have a nice day now you too
nicely done
yeah
Emily I don't I maybe I have as little
memory as Bine does but I don't remember
people on like MLK day doing stuff like
this like all of a sudden just ripping
out of everybody I mean he is wasn't it
supposed to be the nice president that's
what he built himself out to be but
that's the whole shock of it all he
campaigned on being the great unifier
right but instead the enemy has been
coming out of his mouth and it's always
GOP it's always Patriots it's average
Americans it's parents it's every normal
person is the enemy in our president's
eyes what also killed me and it just
ever I mean every day is MLK date to him
in terms of that amount of just root
just botching everything he really has a
um the wake in his the Wake that he
leaves is like it's really disastrous
and that's the thing and that's what I
worry about because I feel like there's
a lot of jokes about it not necessarily
here but in general you know we mock it
it's funny to laugh but it's also
frightening that that is our commander
in chief that he is an utter lack of
absolute
comprehension of the the importance of
the classified documents the importance
of the Southern border the importance of
security all of that anyway but my point
was that he also said during that speech
he said that the Second Amendment from
the moment that it was passed limited
who could buy a gun and what kind of
weapons that they could own and that to
me is an entire illustration of how he
views our government because the second
amendment limited the government the
whole point of the Constitution is that
it limits the government to not infringe
on our rights that we were born with and
the rights that we have that are
unalienable so for him to come in and
say it limits the the American it limits
you because you need an F-15 to destroy
the government just belies the fact that
to him the greatest gift will always be
the biggest government possible and that
is why he's the most dangerous president
we've ever had wow
[Music]
[Applause]
wow geez Kurt I don't know I mean I
don't like Joe Biden but most dangerous
the most dangerous president in the
history of the Watergate worse than
water again but maybe he's proving a
point that maybe presidents aren't that
important he's so vast I think yeah he
might have proved that point yeah
yeah
I don't understand why you would need a
F-15 to fight the didn't the Taliban
like just do that pretty well yes I
think we left a few f-15s with them if
I'm not yes something nice yes that's
your best shot at getting an F-150
that is true cat
yeah I just will never be able to
understand how many people think that
the police are a racist mob of murderers
but then also think they should be the
only ones who are allowed to have guns
yeah I don't get it and yeah we can't
have f-15s but you know the government
can't have f-15s but the government also
has many reasons why it might not want a
carpet bomb its own people like on its
own soil and you know if for him to say
that we have no chance against the
government with AR-15s actually based on
the meaning of a sec the Second
Amendment is an argument for us to have
more powerful weapons it's true not less
power you know what he's doing yeah but
that comment was goading he was like
actually goading he was like looking at
January 6. is that it
but you beat the government with a
Viking hat yeah I want to see you try
but don't you need you need a better gun
but saying that an AR-15 is not a match
for an F-15 doesn't mean it provides no
check knowing that the you know our
population is armed it makes it you know
a lot more costly of a decision for the
government if they were to go ahead and
say all right we got a carpet bomb I'm
like what are you talking about
especially when the carpet bombs with
the same people he's demonizing there's
quite an overlap with military and gun
owners I'm I'm afraid yeah that's like a
hole to you yes I I think the reason he
was beating up on everybody is he
honestly thought it was Rodney King Day
oh foreign
there you go dude
you know you know like you know the
White House Press team was like so
relieved he didn't say that yesterday
because he because he said every other
day did you on that street right
I have a theory I want you to hear me
out on this okay Joe Biden when he goes
off prompter okay because he does have
some type of cognitive dementia and if
you watch him the next time you guys do
you understand what you're watching is a
lottery drawing and what I mean by that
is you know when the girls picking a
lottery numbers on the news they're just
bouncing around in the thing and you get
like 17. yeah that's nine that's why
he's saying things like economy dementia
because they're just flying around in
his head yeah and they're the words he
hears the most don't talk to Joe about
the economy he has dementia you know
what I mean
and that's what happened I'm not even
kidding that's how the happy birthday
video started if you watch it again in
his head happy birthday popped up and
then he started singing it and you could
see his face at the end go oh I don't
know her name listen to the end of the
name he goes happy birthday
because he doesn't know because he got
the wrong
law that's the point well now Trump
would have ended that happy birthday you
fine lovely wonderful lady it was just
coming he would just go off into this
well it really is great you gotta yeah
you got birthdays are great hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else